first off how are you where are you in
the world during this crazy time
i'm in fort lauderdale fort lauderdale
florida and i'm doing great
well we've got season eight of below
deck can you imagine
looking back seven eight years ago when
the show started
did you think oh we'll be on the tv for
nearly a decade
doing this hell no are you
kidding not in my wildest dreams i was
just
i was just trying to get through season
one it's like going home again
did i look like i was over here well
season eight
how are you feeling about it because a
lot has changed between seven and eight
yeah i mean we've gone through a morph
to say the least
i was sad to see kate go and you know i
didn't know how things how the chemistry
would work between my new chief stu and
myself
or between my new chief stew and
everyone else because
you know like when you work with
somebody as long as i've worked with
kate
you can you get a sense for how she's
gonna interact with certain people
in certain personalities and
so you get a feel for how things are
gonna you know transpire or not
during the course of the season when you
learned that she was
stepping away what did you think was
there a moment where you thought
i don't know if i want to do a charter
season without her anymore
you know it it totally caught me off
guard and i was just
never saw it coming i was totally
unprepared
it's like okay
um and it was a long conversation
i mean this went on for you know better
than an hour or so
and i just uh get flabbergasted
for lack of a better term it just hit me
hard and
then i started to think about the
ramifications of it
you know because they were huge yeah
yeah it's one thing to process
oh i'm losing my work buddy but then
there's the world of
bravo that you live in of this reality
show you make and all that it's
it's a lot of it's a domino effect
probably yeah it's kind of like uh
okay she's gone so where does all this
weight fall now
did it put pressure on you i'm like am i
ready for this
uh what kind of pressure does that put
on francesca the new chiefs do because
she's walking in not only having to win
you over
but a whole fan base of people over i i
had such
such empathy for francesca because
you're right
she's coming in she's she's worried
about how she's going to get along with
a new captain
you know am i going to live up to his
standards and she's
obviously going to try extremely hard
and work extremely hard because she is a
consummate professional
and then she's got the fan base to deal
with
how are they going to take to me are
they going to like me are they going to
dislike me
a lot of pressure there that's not your
best case scenario
right what is your message to the
viewers as we go into this new season so
many of them are going to be sad that
kate's gone
what is the message to them about
francesca
francesca is going to do just fine um
[Music]
people are different give them
give them a chance to prove themselves
don't come into the season pre-judging
i i think that would be a mistake on
everyone's part
and that's one of the things i had to
you know look at in the mirror and go
okay
here we go new season new crew suck it
up
and and you really can't measure
somebody
by the vacancy left by somebody else i
think that's an important yeah
it's totally unfair to do that
and so that's that's the one takeaway
that i have for the fans is
do not do not judge francesca by the
vacancy left by kate
judge on her own merit absolutely do you
think there's any chance you could
convince kate to come back
in the future i wouldn't even attempt it
okay
my my dream is for her to come back as a
charter guest
i'm with you on that you and i are on
the same page there and because
i've always thought that kate looked a
hell of a lot more like a charter guest
and
she ever looked like a chiefs too and
she had the attitude sometimes
more of a charter game he does
oh do you remember that that episode
where where she and i were playing
role-playing charter guests what's a
girl gotta do for a drink around these
parts
i haven't been this thirsty since the
great he's waving out
man i'm running out of words to say
i want a drink before i go to the table
yep
rush my case speaking of charter guests
it looks like a charter guest this
season will push you to a point we've
never seen before
or you end a charter early
get your goddamn ass back to this boat
now
your charter just ended what pushes you
to that point
it's something i've never done in my 36
years in yachting
ever before i have never ever
lost it to that degree with anyone
whether it's a crew member or a charter
guest
and so not only was it a first for below
deck it was a first for me
i think a question viewers have a lot is
are
charter guests not on reality tv just as
demanding
and eccentric as the ones we see on
reality tv
there's no difference
i wonder what the poor people are doing
today your crew it's a largely
fresh crew this time around who
impressed you the most out of this new
crew
eddie and eddie is not green
by any stretch of the imagination he's
not new
but i was really very impressed with the
maturation level
of eddie how much he had progressed in
the five years since since we've worked
together
and everyone else that that came on
board i got
i got a really just a pleasant
really pleasant vibe i just felt
wow this is this is going to be good
that was my that was my first
inclination did the inclination
change over time did anybody disappoint
you
um disappoint no would i like to have
seen some
some people progress quicker
or maybe maybe have a better grasp of
what the job was all about as opposed to
what they may have perceived it to be
yeah that may have been true but
i don't think i can't actually say there
was anyone that i was really
disappointed in this year i consider
that a a
major milestone does that mean you
didn't have to buy any plane tickets
home for anybody
no i didn't say that we'll let the
firings begin what
no disappointments that we'll have to
watch and see
how much turnover there is as always
uh this season the tail end of it
intersected with the pandemic hitting
how much did that affect
making the show the charters all that
that
you know when you're when you're on the
middle of the ocean so
you kind of remove yourself from the
outside world
to a certain degree so when some of this
outside world
creeps in you know
one way or another it's kind of like
what the hell's going on out there
and that's the way you view it like
we're fine here
right we're in a little blissfully
unaware bubble we're isolated we're in a
bubble
and you go like okay let's stay focused
everybody
because this is what we have to do and
this is what we have to get done we
still have our jobs to do
you know everybody's worried about your
people back home
but there's nothing that you can do
anything from
where you're at now the world's going to
hell in
handbasking below deck med just wrapped
probably its most
tumultuous season yet and i know you
watch the show you tweet about the show
how do you feel about how things went
down do you think if i wanted you off
the boat that i would use this
huh no it is [ __ ]
because i could have fired you last year
a year before
would you have handled anything
differently uh that's a tough one
yeah i i think anybody that knows me can
look at some situations that transpired
on below deck med and go like
yeah no i wouldn't have done it that way
i have a different style of doing things
obviously i prefer my style
otherwise i wouldn't do it
so yeah there there are some things i
would have done different
and i'm not i'm not saying right or
wrong
i'm saying different i hope people can
understand
and are able to differentiate between
the two hannah has said
the only way she would come back to
below deck is if she were to
be able to work with you would you want
to work with hannah as a chief student
i don't see any reason why i wouldn't
work with hannah but i mean
and i'm and hannah probably realizes
this from watching several seasons of
below deck that
you know on my boat it's not a democracy
you don't get a vote
yeah it's this is the way we do things
there's no crying and yachting we'll
circle back one last question
if you had uh you had to sum up season
eight with just one word
what is your word for this season one
word
it's still fun and that's why
i still want to do it is because when it
stops being fun that's when you won't
see me anymore
so that you'll know it's time to walk
away when you stop having fun
exactly when it stops being fun i'll
probably stop doing it but uh
so far it hasn't but i imagine there's a
difference between
when the show stops being fun and one
being a captain stops being fun
i i think i might be the exception to
that rule
just because i don't consider myself a
celebrity
i consider myself a captain that just
gets filmed doing his job
and it's like i tell the crew every year
do your job everything else is going to
take care of itself
[Music]